It was at the 11th  hour of the 11th day of the 11th month in 1918...
...that the guns fell silent around Europe.
The legacy of the devastating loss of life in the First World War...
...has shaped the way we remember our dead.
Many of the traditions now so familiar come from the determination of one generation:...
...not to forget what they've lived through.
The idea of the two-minute silence,...
...observed at that 11th hour came in a letter to a newspaper.
Published in a London evening news in May 1919,...
...it caught the imagination of King George V.
A royal proclamation was issued, calling for the silence...
...so that the thoughts of everybody...
...should be concentrated on reverent remembrance of the glorious dead.